in 2009 we had more than 33 0 charge in
solutions consumers should be given a
central role in particular if
manufacturers are only allowed to sell
mobile phones without the charger which
seems to be a promising option from the
environmental point of view these would
entail large consumers awareness
campaigns and consumers should benefit
from any reduction in costs being passed
on through lower prices for stand-alone
devices many of us have been advocating
for more than 10 years for a solution to
this very simple problem the amount of
cables and chargers produced and thrown
away each year is simply unacceptable we
expect 3 concrete actions to be
undertaken firstly the Commissioner has
to show leadership and stop letting tech
giant's dictate the standouts secondly
having the possibility to use the same
common charger for multiple devices the
consumer should not be forced to pay for
additional charges when buying new
devices and thirdly the Commission
should propose quality standards for
treating a waste and help Member States
to reach a waste collection targets
satellites potentially saw whole Kousaka
before circular economy tea from Kia the
piano notes a Lucifer football school of
a million's school let's hope total net
each mere note hey stone Elena a mood
ring sohara the hold of it - knocks -
Alex from the favela passes for fabric
counter it's very new sheets that is a
dialogue on food una blight worker
Duprey diesel lock emission persist
acute install a band veloute
do not use three of a club sauce the
result o'clock on a lob tzfat Lima
solution in La Paz acceptable policy to
elicit win over PR in Myakka Tommy do
you take on Fergus PR la pollution
hopefully sauce program a choise lucky
sir Sushi's recommission Toffler
souvenirs as yet
namu Amida Vitas the new system the
retreat madonna calpro señora de la voix
inactive benji a granita him at part of
pistachio Jean the electron is knocked
over Duke shots on Cove Donovan who
neuropathy position didn t she entered
on Raj Nair